hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast this is our
204th live stream even number not prime
we are obviously not in our temporary
permanent location we are in a very
temporary location in fact we are on a
friends boat in the Caribbean which
means among other things that we are
using a whole bunch of technology and
pushing it to limits that it may or may
not be capable of handling we will see
so please bear with us as we attempt to
Uplink through satellites using a mess
of cables and devices that are all in
theory capable of bringing you the Dark
Horse podcast uh in full Living Color
that's right so I'm Dr Brett Weinstein
this is Dr Heather Hing that part you
knew and then you're going to hear some
things that you may or may not know well
we encourage you to come join us on
Rumble and the watch party on locals and
uh we're also on YouTube of course and
uh you can find us everywhere you can
find podcasts as
always um we encourage you to check us
out at our store darkh hor store.org and
we're going to move really the rest of
the stuff um that we're going to tell
you about where to find us and such to
the end except for our sponsors we have
as usual three sponsors right at the top
of the hour uh who make products or
offer services that we really and truly
vouch for so let us begin those now all
right let's do that our first sponsor is
American Heart for gold if you're here
listening to us you probably already
know just how incompetent and unstable
our instit institutions are becoming
interest rates are Skyhigh we are caught
between runaway inflation and recession
while being assured that all is fine the
cost of food housing Medical Care
schools everything is climbing our
leaders are increasingly nonsensical all
of this threatens businesses jobs and
retirements retirement funds finding
ways to secure your nest egg and
insulate your wealth is more important
than ever and add adding precious metals
to your assets is a great way to
stabilize your Investments and protect
yourself financially American Heart for
gold is a precious metals dealer that
can help you do just that American Heart
for gold helps individuals and families
protect their wealth by diversifying
with precious metals they make it simple
and easy to protect your savings and
retirement account with physical gold
and silver with one short phone call
they can have physical gold and silver
delivered right to your door or inside
your IRA or 401K they are the highest
rated firm in the country with an A+
rating from the Better Business Bureau
and thousands of satisfied clients and
if you call them right now they will
give you up to $5,000 of free silver on
your first qualifying order contact them
today by visiting the link in the
episode description below or call
8668281166
8281 1117 or text Darkhorse to
98899 that's 866 82811109
Darkhorse to
98899 all right our second sponsor this
week is the wellness company
world-renowned experts like
Dr I think I know who you're getting at
is it Dr Peter McCulla yes it is there
you have it I'm GNA be Tongue Tied all
day today I'm going to start over our
second sponsor this week is the wellness
company world renowned experts like Dr
Peter McCulla have partnered with the
wellness company to create real change
in healthcare the wellness company
offers a wide variety of supplements and
services including telea Health
Emergency medical kits which include
evercon and teams of medical
professionals that can assist in helping
patients
from I don't know how to read I can add
live it can assist patients kick the
Pharma habit with the freedom from
Pharma program there's an extra word in
the script yeah you've run into put
we'll use it for something later okay
we're talk okay remember it's from from
is the extra word all right anybody out
there needs a from we will auction it
off at the end of the episode the
wellness company which is awesome has
all unlike this adri has all sorts of
useful and important products thank you
for bailing me out there man you're
welcome personally I'm a fan of their
Mito support Mito is in mitochondria
which is formulated to provide energy
both physical and mental and their
spikes their Spike support formula is
their most popular product it's useful
not only for those who've been
vaccinated but for anyone who may be
suffering from long CO as well as the
wellness company says in the website if
you're looking to get back to that
pre-co feeling their Spike support
formula can help Spike support is maybe
the combination of natural ingredients
like ninis dandelion root extract
selenium black sativa extract Irish sea
moss and green tea extract these
ingredients all contain immune boosting
capabilities and the nin specifically
has been used by the Japanese for
decades because of its ability to
dissolve blood clots but more recently
nines has been shown to be able to break
down Spike proteins in the bloodstream
and even block them from binding to
cells Dr McCulla says quote out of all
the available therapies I have used in
my practice and among all the proposed
detoxification agents I believe ninas
and related peptides hold the greatest
promise for patients at this time end
quote whether you've taken the vaccine
or just had Co if you're concerned about
circulating Spike proteins go to tww c.
Health Darkhorse and use code Darkhorse
to save 15% on your first order that's
tww c. Heald Darkhorse code Darkhorse to
save
15% and our final sponsor this week is
seed a probiotic that really works if
you've tried probiotics before and got
nothing out of it try seed it's designed
differently from other probiotics it's
designed better it actually works seed
helps improve the health of your gut
microbiome which means that it supports
you becoming healthier overall our
resident gut microbes directly impact
the development and function of the
immune system even before we're born
microbes inform our immune system
teaching our body how to distinguish
between benign substances and pathogenic
antigens that is substances that our
body does not recognize as its own you
can support your gut immune axis in a
variety of ways including by
prioritizing sleep new research suggests
that the gut microbiome has its own
circadian clock and that changes to your
normal rhythms like being on airplanes
can disrupt your microbes and the
important functions they perform
prioritizing regular sleep can thus help
keep your gut immune access healthy
seeds DS1 daily symbiotic also supports
your gut immune AIS seed is a
plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic with
24 strains that have been clinically or
scientifically studied for their
benefits 16 of those 24 strains are
specifically geared towards digestive
health and four of the 24 probiotic
strains are known to promote healthy
skin your skin like your gut has its own
microb I seed supports both gut and skin
Health seed is also free from 14 major
classes of Allens including but not
limited to sugar animal products soy
gluten peanut glyphosate Dairy shellfish
and corn and seed is basically double
HED with its capsule in capsule design
it is engineered to maintain viability
through your digestive tract until it
reaches your colon where you want it and
the same design makes it resistant to
oxygen moisture and heat meaning that no
Refrigeration is necessary among other
things this means that you can travel
with it which I just have it's wonderful
it's great to be be able to travel with
it seed's daily symbiotic supports gut
skin and heart health and micronutrient
synthesis people who use seed often
report improvements to their digestive
function in 24 to 48 hours so start a
new healthy habit today visit seed.com
Darkhorse and use code Darkhorse to
redeem 25% off your first month of seeds
ds01 daily symbiotic that's seed.com
Darkhorse and use code Darkhorse at
checkout all right what did the sea
otter say to the clam that it was about
to break open I don't know stop being
shellfish I'm sorry it just something
about seed and being yes exactly
exactly the fact that shellfish is
called out as an allergen in that caus
me to so there it is a dad joke right
right off top spontaneously occurred yep
yes that's that's fine that's good um so
before we get into the meat of today I
just want to point out that tomorrow the
21st of December is the solstice the
shortest the the shortest day of the
year is always a little bit of a strange
construction right uh the days are the
same length uh throughout the year
slight slightly changing but uh
imperceptibly so uh and so the northern
winter solstice is the day in which you
get the least light uh even though it is
um not
actually uh the latest sunrise or the
early Sunset those those are a slightly
different off slightly offset from when
the solstice
is I'm going to have to puzzle through
that with a piece of paper later to
convince myself that that's possible no
but you if you're in the northern
hemisphere which almost all of you are
um although we got some Stats today
which suggest there are a lot of viewers
in Sydney hello fine Southern friends um
that uh if you're in the northern
hemisphere the shortest the no
the sorry make it right uh the earliest
sunset has already happened for you and
you are now kind of like hanging out at
whatever if if you haven't moved spaces
if you haven't Mo geographies and and um
and it may actually even be a minute or
two later depending on how far north you
are that it was at its earliest time
whereas your Sunrise is going to going
to continue to creep later into like
early January before it reverses course
so combine those two and today is the
shortest day of the year um but the
period between those things is the
shortest
and is the other thing an artifact of
human time zones no the other the um you
mean the uh the sunrise sunset times
apparently it's about um the not totally
circular orbit of the sun of the sorry
of the Earth around the Sun got it all
right yeah okay so that's that's
Solstice for you it's pretty wild you
know I think this is one of those things
you ought to pay attention to annually
it's a good way of marking time in many
ways it's more useful than a birth
birthday that you know has significance
Beyond you and there's two soles and
therefore two equinoxes every year so
they're they're really they're beautiful
moments of the year to consider to do
some sort of Celebration and many
cultures do in fact on the solstices few
are on the equinoxes but it's um it's
they're also astronomically meaningful
moments and um you know probably and I
think you mentioned this maybe last week
on on Darkhorse um Hanukkah has sort of
been upgraded within the Jewish
tradition in part uh I think um to help
Jewish kidss not feel totally left out
of the brewhaha that uh
commercialization of Christmas has
become um but it you know it is a
festival of lights so it's its proximity
you know it moves around a little bit
over the years but um its proximity to
the solstice is no accident and the
timing of Christmas itself May in you
know we don't know actually um when the
man that would become called Jesus who
would become to be called Jesus was born
um but his the celebration of his birth
right around the solstice as well may
also be no accident but instead a
replacement of um some of the so-called
pagan holidays which were honoring this
you know much more ancient and
astronomically uh meaningful reality
that is the solstice yeah and uh to the
extent I think I'm no biblical scholar
but my understanding is that the
evidence suggests that Jesus was not
born anywhere near Christmas and so
therefore the idea of creating a
celebration that is nominally a birth
celebration ation at this moment that
happens to be uh right about the
solstice um suggests that celebrating
the solstice is probably something that
populations which did it outcompeted
those that were similar that didn't yeah
and and so there's something to be said
for marking the time in a useful way you
know as things as things are getting
colder things are also getting brighter
right exactly um so anyway who knows
what what the explanation is for so many
cultures having found that moment a good
time to celebrate but undoubtedly there
is one given the number of times it's
been discovered so by our current
calendar thinking this is the first day
of winter um by some other ways of
thinking this would be midwinter um but
it gets it only gets colder from here if
you are in in the north you know the
farther north you get but the days are
getting longer um albo and accumulated
cold U being what they are though means
that uh you know through solid
mid-February or longer uh it's not going
to get nicer out depending on what you
view as nice but your days are going to
be getting longer and I just want to say
before we get into most of what we're
talking about today that I'm going to
finish today with a little reading from
and and I did this actually the very
first Christmas season that we were on
air with dark r a little reading from
Charles Dickens A Christmas Carol um so
we'll finish with a little bit a little
bit of Christmas spirit and cheer uh
since this will be our last live stream
um before Christmas and I we be back um
actually on the Thursday after Christmas
and uh be bringing in the New Year sure
after all right New Year should there be
one we will be there to
celebrate um there will be be a New Year
yes yeah almost undoubtedly the chances
are spectacularly High okay
um so let us talk about uh the elephant
in the room and I am not talking about
Donald Trump he's not the elephant in
the room but this uh decision in the
Colorado Supreme Court um declaring him
ineligible to be on their ballot uh
based on the 14th Amendment is here and
forever after going to be some kind of
elephant in some kind of room you you
were suggesting the decision is elephant
time it is it is infantile elephanttine
it is uh it is a remarkable moment in
American history and I will say this you
know this train wreck that uh follows
the candidacy and then presidency of
Donald Trump just continues so in some
ways this is yet one more jaw-dropping
event that is going to be the result of
this one unusual person having taken
this unusual path and having
demonstrated that the duopoly was not
unbeatable which of course has enraged
everything that is using the duopoly in
order to maintain and gain further power
so anyway yeah we keep living that uh
that storyline and it's terrifying it's
insane that people would take a system
that functions as well as ours does and
jeopardize it over their um
Petty inability to accept this one
person and his popularity it's it's like
you know the nastiest mean girl politics
from high school having taken over the
governance structure um so that it just
can't even see straight um so there's a
lot to to say about this the 14th
Amendment owes to an Era the Civil War
era in which Insurrection actually meant
Insurrection
and the problem here there's no point in
us rehashing the details uh of the
decision and even pursuing its precise
meaning or what will happen if and when
the Supreme Court of the United States
reviews the decision and what that will
mean if the Supreme Court overturns this
decision as they should
um there's lots of places you can get
that analysis but the real
question is I think how this relates to
what we have discussed here under the
heading of the cartisian crisis and I'm
just going to remind people of two
pieces of uh cartisian toolkit cartisian
meaning relative to uh
rart that are relevant and they're
connected one um is that Renee
Dart had a kind of crisis of he had an
existential crisis that was based in the
fact that he realized that almost
everything that he believed to be a fact
was not something that he had
established himself it was something
that he had taken on somebody else's
Authority and no ration person thinks
that taking other people's word for
what's a fact is a good idea so looking
at this the obvious responsible thing to
do from his perspective was to start
establishing things and then the deeper
he dug the more he realized that
actually there's almost nothing you
could establish down to bedrock because
at the bottom level what even are you
that's doing the establishing and how do
you even know that you exist and so
there's nothing it all just runs through
your fingers like water and so anyway he
generates what I swear is not a actual
proof of anything now you'll get lots of
good arguments from lots of very smart
people um that I've got this wrong but
the idea is I think therefore I am is at
the very least a one-of-a-kind proof
that we accept under very special rules
because we don't have any choice either
that or it's not a proof at all it's a
it's a bit of circular logic and the
reason that it's not a real proof in the
normal sense is that I can show you if
we've got a mathematical proof or
something that follows that form I can
say here is the proof right and you can
look at it and you can say all right
here are the assumptions and on the
basis of deductive logic if the
assumptions hold then this series of
extrapolations is so Ironclad that the
conclusion must follow the only way for
it to be wrong is for the assumptions in
it to be incorrect right because the
steps are laid out and there are no gaps
that's what a real proof is
now the carts proof if it works at all
it works on the basis that in order to
have the proof running you must exist
existence is a prerequisite for the
proof to be anything but that means I
don't know if there was a Renee deart I
don't know that he ever had this thought
I don't know that he ever said he I you
know kajo AR gosm I don't know any of
those things I can't establish that I'm
taking all of that on Authority so the
only thing I can do is take his proof
and instead of AC acting it as a proof
on paper that's Ironclad I can say never
mind if Renee Dart existed or said any
of this stuff I can run that thing and
inside my head I can establish that I
exist I can't establish that he existed
but I can establish that I exist okay
that's a weird proof right that it's
like it's only locally true inside the
person running it that's not how proofs
work so whatever this thing is it's an
unusual artifact and my claim as
longtime viewers will know
is that it is cruddy as it is oneoff as
it is mislabeled as a proof as it seems
to be it is absolutely essential that
you accept it because really you're
stuck at a a bifurcation at a a fork in
the road the fork in the road is either
you can fail to accept it you can say
well I still don't know if I exist and
then maybe it's your obligation to
establish that first you're not going to
do better than Renee Dart so you're not
going to establish it you'll spend your
whole life trying you'll fail and you'll
accomplish nothing because you were busy
with that your whole life or you can say
I accept the proof that frees me to go
do something else of value and if the
proof turns out to be wrong what have I
lost because I guess I didn't exist
right so anyway it's that choice and
that choice at at a return on investment
level is a very powerful argument for
accepting Rene's deckards proof as if it
was good which we all do you know it's
good enough um but the problem here is
we have now gotten to a place where the
amount that is current that we must
accept on faith is
Extreme our ability to check events that
they mean what we're told they mean is
nil and we exist in separate Echo
chambers that have totally different
interpretations of extrinsic stuff so
we're stuck our ability to check is
nil unless we happen to live in the
place where the event is happening and
even then well but I mean I think this
is part of we have heard that part of
why people uh tuned into Darkhorse in
the summer of 2020 was not just because
we were speaking truth about what was
going on with regard to the aftermath of
uh George Floyd's death uh and the rise
of Dei and so-called anti-racism and
such was but it was also that Portland
as one of the epicenters of stent stupid
during that whole thing was where we
lived and we would go down town and
observe you know the nightly transitions
from peaceful protest into violent riots
you know I mean this we we could
actually see it and that doesn't mean
that you guys were seeing it but if you
had come to otherwise assess that we
were trustworthy reporters of what we
were seeing you were now just one step
away as opposed to us saying well we
read in the New York Times you know or
you know we read in even you know any
number of places like no actually we
went and saw this and here are some of
our pictures and this is what's actually
going on so um but it it does it it I
think it that does speak to part of why
sort of Citizen journalism when it is
actually done is so valuable now because
if you have come to trust that that
person with the camera is someone that
you can trust well it's their eyes then
I'm I'm going to look through their eyes
I don't know about cbs's eyes or CNN's
eyes and the New York Times eyes I don't
trust those people um but this guy with
a YouTube channel or c Cera you what
whatever um that guy's trustworthy and
that is uh it's a great demonstration of
actually where where we're headed here
which is how many links in the chain
have to be what you think they are in
order for that to work and the fact is
it does work we are trustworthy
perfectly trustworthy no we could easily
misperceive something Mis analyze it
because we do the analysis in front of
you in large measure you're in some
position to detect whether or not we're
making sense or R lying to ourselves or
whatever you might detect but anyway the
point is yes you can depend on somebody
who has proven thems trustworthy in some
way that you have to regard as
provisional because what if it later
turns out that the thing you thought
they were right about they were wrong
about how do they handle it that sort of
thing but assuming these people are
trustworthy then I can trust that they
at least saw what they said they saw
right and I can't establish all the
things they didn't say you know what if
you and I had gone to a
protest and we had seen the target
of federal law enforcement agents
outside a courthouse and we had reported
this and then it had turned out that
that had been a training exercise and we
had misunderstood where we were right so
the exact observation doesn't tell you
for sure that the thing is what it says
it is no but I mean this this this is
exactly and this is a topic that we come
back to over and over and over again
which is basically the philosophy of
science like you know what how is and
epistemology how is it that we make
claims of truth and how is it that we
understand what we believe to be true to
be true so you know science just was
thrown under the bus by fouchi and
Company during during Co in which he
declared that he himself was science and
to disagree with him was to disagree
with science and of course that is not
now nor has it ever been how science
works that's how Authority works that's
how Faith Works um that's you know
that's that's how you know Celestial and
wouldbe Celestial authorities
work observation of something and
especially if you can record it and show
what you observed as close as possible
through the L that you observed it to a
public to an audience and then saying
and now let me tell you what I think it
means like we do both but we try to make
it clear even when we aren't explicit we
make it clear like this is what I saw
and this is what I think it means this
is the observation and this is the
interpretation and these two things are
both absolutely necessary in making
sense of the world and we can't trust
either of those things in the modern
media landscape right we can't trust the
supposed observations what happened what
are the facts or the interpretation what
does it mean what does it imply what
does that say about these other things
that happened over here right we can't
trust either of those things and they're
conflated they're just wrapped up
together as if it's one media block as
if you know that's that's all you have
to do is get to a source that can do
that thing well and by and large those
outfits those people those systems that
are good at one are not inherently good
at the other and there are a lot of ways
to talk you know there I've got
this we'll get get here later but um
there are a lot of ways to say okay well
is it this or that is it you know is it
observation or is it interpretation is
it Intuition or logic like you know
which of the two things on which side of
the diad are you right now and I've got
a list of a lot of these like is it a or
b both of which in each of these cases
and just to take the two I just used
like intuition and logic observation and
interpretation they are all necessary
they are all important that we all be
able to do them but one of the mistakes
that is made um by people assessing
media is they say Well I this media
system has to get both right or oh I can
tell that they interpreted it wrong
therefore the reporting on what actually
happened must be wrong as well when
those are usually separable things
separable entities what is it that
happened and what does it mean yeah
actually I increasingly find that to the
extent that we are denied good news
sources
that I have to go to new sources that I
absolutely do not trust on
interpretation but there are certain
events that I could rely on them to tell
me happened right there are events that
I could rely on them to tell me happened
but I could not rely on them to tell me
if they hadn't right so anyway there's a
there's a weird Balancing Act to do but
let's go back to the Trump phenomenon
you've got a the 14th Amendment and a
provision that prevents somebody who has
been involved in actual ins Resurrection
from um being on the ballot now why do
you need that well in the mindset of
people who had faced the near
destruction of the
Republic over an
Insurrection it is not impossible to
imagine a highly popular
insurrectionist and so this provision is
placed in the Constitution as a
protection against a scenario that is
not unimaginable mhm mapping this
scenario onto Donald Trump
is a it's a terrifying abuse of
logic but it's an abuse of logic for
reasons that one cannot establish in
absolute terms Donald Trump was
President the folks who thought that was
a asteroid headed for Earth were wrong
okay you say a lot of things about Trump
I wish and in fact maybe I'm just going
to break the habit of always saying this
isn't my guy I didn't vote for him I
don't want him to be president I don't
think he has the characteristics that
make a good president but he did a lot
of good stuff and top of the list I
would point out and I'm going to come
back to this is no new Wars now no new
Wars is something that virtually
every American should be biased
towards there are moments at which you
have to go to war but the bias ought to
be look war is a last
resort starting new ones is bad it takes
whatever you might be doing economically
that would be productive for all of us
that would create a surplus with which
we could do the stuff that great
civilizations do get squandered in stuff
that blows up on a battlefield and is
never seen again it opens up routes for
corruption it obviously creates
tremendous tragedy uh so by against War
ought to be the default but there are a
whole bunch of people who aren't biased
against War because they make money
through war and so in any case a
president who didn't start any new Wars
when every other recent president has
would certainly be a problem for those
whose business model depends on the fact
that we always have a reason to start a
new war and if we don't have one we'll
make one right so one reason this guy
might be targeted as an insurrectionist
is not an antipathy to America for which
I don't see any evidence I think this
guy has a different priority but hatred
for America no I don't I don't see any
evidence of that so the
um there is a desire to make it
impossible for this person to ascend to
the office there is at least one reason
that people who are themselves being
deeply unpatriotic might want to prevent
that using any tool that their disposal
especially in light of the popularity of
the man especially at the moment and the
idea that you might then invoke this
exotic prohibition against Insurrection
showing up on the ballot right is it's a
shocking departure from normaly and
decency and all of that on the other
hand we are in a cartisian crisis and
there are those who think that what I've
just said as much as what I've said
seems to me perfectly obvious and
utterly secure
there are those who think that the
existential threat represented by this
person even though he was President for
4 years and we were not destroyed and
not even nearly so um that that is
exactly the reason for which the rip
cords that have been placed in various
places have been placed
now even that I would say is
preposterous the fact is the
Constitution does not have
um you know except s for epidemics or
you
know uh reality TV stars ascending to
the presidency it just doesn't haveen
for good reason because if it did then
that would be the whole game right and
in fact the sense that people think that
the exceptions exist is
[Music]
um it is now the game creating the
impression that the circumstances are
such that we now have to pull these
levers that largely don't exist um you
know is now where we are and that
requires the public to be dragged into
irreconcilable narratives you know the
reality that I see I know is completely
incompatible even with the narrative
that my parents see right and you know
we get along
but there is you know as soon as we get
over into the territory that the New
York Times covers every day it's not
possible to find common ground in which
yeah so the destruction of a shared
analysis no not analysis a shared set of
facts right and that's exactly it that's
that's it again right like we're not we
can't even get to the interpretation
part right we can't even get to the
analysis part the part where we get to
use logic the part where we get to
reveal ourselves as descendants of the
Enlightenment no if we can't even agree
on facts we are stuck there at the most
fundamental level of like it's nearly
even human level right like there are a
lot of organisms that should be able to
do this that aren't human and we can't
even agree on this can't even agree on
this and how anybody thinks that there
is a route forward there you know there
are those who are I well at best there
are those who are narrowly gaming our
capacity to make sense of the world for
their own purposes whether that's the
ability to start new Wars when they need
new Wars or the ability to um TR
transfer wealth from others to
themselves through the tax system which
is of course war is one way to do that
whatever whatever it is that they are
using their unearned power for the
ability to maintain it requires the rest
of us to be too confused to align right
if we can agree that the average person
is getting screwed by A system that is
increasingly
disinterested in promoting their
well-being and it is now taken up
keeping them confused fulltime and there
are those of us out here struggling to
make sense while something is struggling
to confuse sense um and you know there's
obviously a huge range of how successful
people are at doing that but um that
battle does not leave
a um a coherent future for anybody
really you know short term yes it puts
certain people way ahead but it's not
obvious that they have a long-term plan
at all they may be just too zoomed in on
not losing their immediate power and
they may be undermining themselves long
term and the rest of us yes are going to
pay a terrible price for what they're up
to but maybe we all suffer from it in
the end
but the question that we are honing in
on here
is what is the method that we can
deploy that prevents people from that
gives us the capacity to make sense
faster than others can can tangle our
sense making such that we can navigate
coherently and not uh become divided
over whether or not um Trump is a
self-obsessed
needy but uh non-hostile to
America um popular candidate or whether
he is the end of America encapsulated in
one
person right we can't disagree over that
right and um yet we do
so this leads me to something that's
going to seem very disconnected which is
a tweet that was forwarded to me
by uh the Tweet is by Tim Kelly Dr Tim
Kelly it's not somebody I know well but
anyway I found the Tweet very
interesting it lays out a an argument
for
um yeah you want to show the tweet and
then uh show the first chart from
it it lays out an argument for why the
Mind fails to
properly incorporate evidence of certain
kinds
um and basically the argument I'm not
going to go deeply into it because
actually this isn't going to be the
focus of our
discussion but the idea is that there is
evidence that the Mind functions in a
basian way that is according to Bas
theorem and the simple description of
how this works is that you have priors
which is your understanding of how the
universe functions walking into a
situation and then you have evidence and
that these two things are effectively
like curves that get multiplied by each
other to bring you to your new position
the idea being that the incorporation of
new evidence adjusts your understanding
of how the world works and in many
limited circumstances that's clearly
true and the fact that there's
neurological evidence that says the
brain does this is fascinating um now
the problem is so so the argument that
uh that Tim Kelly lays out which he um
in part credits to a friend of his
mathematician uh is that there that in
the math there is a defect which causes
the mind not to be able to update when a
prior is held with particular intensity
now I think the description in the Tweet
which we will link in the description
here I think that the argument that is
presented is actually flawed it points
to something interesting but I think
what it's really saying is that when you
hold a belief with sufficient strength
then a piece of evidence that is
sufficiently contradictory to it is not
multiplied by it but is in fact thrown
out as an outlier now throwing out
outliers is not an inherently wrong
thing to do it's a question of whether
or not your reason for throwing them out
is valid and to take an example if we
were trying to figure out whether the
globe was warming and we had data from a
station at a particular spot
and we had um you
know daily readings at noon for a 100
years and they were all
between uh you know whatever they were
between uh 30° F and
105° fenhe I'm not sure what location
that would describe but whatever that's
the range and then you've got a reading
that is
204° well you could throw it out as an
outlier it never got to 204° you know it
didn't and so the point is that's not
really evidence what that is is a sensor
went bad or something so you're
justified in throwing out an outlier
sometimes but if what you do is you walk
into a situation and you have a very
strongly held belief and something says
oh that strong belief isn't right and
you throw it out because it contradicts
that belief not because there's reason
to think it's an error then you're
making a logical mistake right now
outliers exist for various reasons and
uh the remarkable habit of throwing out
outliers in much of statistical analysis
is egregious and it fails to distinguish
between the fact that uh you know es
especially uh when it's you know remote
machines that are just you know blipping
on at particular moments and there will
be errors in what was collected but also
with regard to humans um there will be
errors in the data and sometimes
outliers indicate that the system is not
what you thought it was and so if your
if your rule is throw out outliers uh
you are damning yourself to continuing
to believe and what you continue to in
what you already believe yes that's the
problem is that there's an art to
throwing out only outliers for which
there's a justification and if you don't
if you are not practiced at the art and
I use that term carefully then you end
up with a
verificationist um understanding and a
verificationist understanding is of
course you know the cardinal sin of what
I will call a paparian worldview so
anyway I know that this is seems complex
and and um maybe too philosophical to be
important but it's it's really the
opposite we are watching civilization
decco here over a failure to agree on
simple matters of fact and obvious
extrapolations from
them
and what I want to argue so we've got
Tim Kelly who points out that basian
reasoning has a flaw and I'm not again
I'm not certain that the flaw he's found
is actually a flaw in basy and reasoning
it's a flaw in something about the way
the Mind applies this particular method
but um I wanted to lay out an argument
and the argument is you've got different
ways of doing an analysis you've got um
what I would call an Arista tilian or
bonian scient ific
approach um you know standard um
observation hypothesis um prediction
test thesis synthesis or thesis
antithesis synthesis yep you've got the
paparian version of this in which
falsification takes on its special
capacity to protect us from
um from reinforcing pre-existing not
Notions um you've got basian analysis
and then you've got uh other folks who
are doing something entirely different
you you've got folks who ascribe to a
worldview in which there is some uh
organizing principle with an
intelligence to it people who are
devoted to a religious worldview who
don't
necessarily and I will come back to why
this sounds wrong but do necessarily
care what the output of all of these
scientific or rigorous analytical
processes say it's not going to budge
them off of some core belief about the
most fundamental facts of the universe
so the upshot of all of this I
think
is how does the Mind work right we are
told oh there's evidence that it works
in a basian way and if it does that
explains why people are unwilling to
depart from core beliefs that they hold
very strongly it's a mathematical issue
right that the math does not cause you
know if it if you presented them with a
small upgrade to their model they might
move just a little bit if you present
them a large upgrade they abandon the
upgrade as an outlier and they don't
move at all right so that's a paradox
presumably the larger uh departure from
their world you should move them farther
but in fact it moves them less right it
sounds like oh the math is bad in the
brain why would a brain be built that
way well my argument is going to be it
ain't in fact what you have is a
mind first of all realize from our
perspective the mind is built to solve
evolutionary puzzles what does it mean
to solve an evolutionary puzzle well it
means that you take you make the most of
the opportunity that you have in terms
of getting your genes as far into the
future as you can that's what it means
to solve well wait I didn't hear you say
anything about being right oh no being
right isn't involved to the extent that
the Universe cares if you're right it
cares if you're effective at something
and in our case it cares at the level of
whether we get our genes into the future
well what if believing wrong things gets
your genes into the future cool then
that's what you're going to do
so that is simultaneously living with a
mind that is perfectly capable of doing
science and doing it brilliantly right
now a scientific worldview will have you
accept things on the basis you know I
think in the upgraded form that a
falsification has caused you to abandon
some primitive way of thinking in favor
of a new way of thinking that may
actually be bad for you right science
doesn't care whether the conclusion that
you come to gets your genes into the
future
but it is true that on average knowing
more will provide you opportunities to
get your jeans into the future in ways
that you might Miss if you knew less so
there's some conflict is selection
really just getting you to believe
whatever is useful even if it's wrong is
it trying to get you to figure out
what's right it's doing both but it's
doing
those in a way that presumably does not
have you obligated to one or the other
right
so one or the other which I I I lost the
end there okay so let's say we've got a
science person and a faith person which
one is ahead in the evolutionary game of
getting into the future well the science
person has an
advantage that Advantage is that they
can figure out what's true and that may
provide some opportunities but the faith
person
has ways of thinking about what might be
true that are proven over very long
periods of time
and so neither of these is a recipe for
getting into the future they are both
tools in the toolkit of getting into the
future and in fact the having both of
those people in the same population
means that you can have the advantages
of both things living in the same
place I guess I'm stuck there are a lot
of these ways in which we switch modes
that I've been thinking about a lot
lately and and I'm I'm startled to hear
a science versus Faith description
because that seems to me like it's one
of the ancient or at least several
hundreds of years old ways that we have
that human beings have supposedly sort
of come to blows
intellectually um that is almost
precisely one of the least common ones
at the moment it really doesn't feel
like at the moment we're in a science
versus Faith landscape at least not as
the people who are claiming to be
speaking for science understand it
because the people who are claiming to
be speaking for science are very often
engaged in faith-based exercises in
faith-based
um you know
authoritarian uh authoritarian trusting
exercises
and
um I find instead I find you know many
people of Faith many people who describe
themselves as of a faith which I do not
which you do
not in fact do engage in scientific in
critical scientific thinking every day
right and they engage in logic
[Music]
and
um I'm so confused by what is going on
right
now they engage in in logic and
rationality and also in in following
their intuition and in observing things
just as those who are doing science are
supposed to be doing
and I'm not
sure maybe you're going somewhere that I
don't I don't know but that felt like
you went a lot of places I didn't you
didn't tell me you were going and I
didn't I thought we were going other
places and I'm not sure how useful at
the moment it is like especially given
that you wanted to open by talking about
Colorado and Trump and the Supreme Court
like that is Being Framed by you know
the people supposedly on our side on you
know on the left right uh as uh you know
the Trump people the Trump voters are
mostly of faith and they're not the
science people and that's not the way it
is at all but I'm not that's that's not
the way it is and so I don't know I
don't know what science versus Faith is
doing here exactly so I'm building up an
argument okay then then keep going well
my point is not that those science
versus Faith people exist very much they
did in fact we overlapped with a
worldview in which there was was
absolute denial of darwinian evolution
as an explanation for the diversity of
species and that has largely given way
even as we have been functioning in that
space to people who have faith
ultimately in a Creator actually taking
on a scientific understanding and
pursuing um pursuing a hybrid
explanation now I'm not arguing for or
against that here what I what the the
argument I'm trying to make
is you correctly point out as we've
argued here many times that even a
scientist has to have faith in order to
do their work that they're hold on so
the point is a scientific toolkit does
not limit itself a functional scientific
toolkit May limit itself in its
description to only you know valid
scientific things like the formation of
hypothesis and predictions and tests but
a functional scientist of the type that
actually makes real progress is
borrowing from another mode a mode that
we often do not acknowledge absolutely
and I am understanding that mode as a
number of things that you have not
mentioned and I do not see it as
particularly the purview of those with
faith I see it and I don't want to give
away too much because this is like a big
project that I'm working on but I see it
as a place where where Beauty exists and
why do we appreciate beauty and a place
where narrative and story exist and what
you know is truth and validity in story
even maybe especially when it is fiction
because what is it that is so appealing
to us about story and why do archetypes
exist and you know those that is the
thing that exists in separate in in sort
of CounterPoint to the logic and the
rationality and the interpretation of
what is often short-handed for people
into like oh the science is just it's
the data and it's once you have the
numbers and it's how you interpret and
that's not of of course that's not true
right right and like you know you
describe you sort of shorthand what what
bacon described as a scientific method
and it absolutely includes observation
and also it's a cycle it returns to
itself and says okay now that you know
something you know go back out and see
you know as Agy wrote you know take the
facts into your own hands and see for
yourself right like that is 100% part of
what science is not oh you've got some
numbers um you know plug it into an
algorithm and see what it spits out I
agree with that and I wanted to add
something I was not intending to limit
the world to some cartoonish Faith
versus science thing within the
scientific worldview you now have
rationalists rationalists who subscribe
to this basian idea and the basian idea
is a sophistication it is one that
clearly we now generally can see has a
failure mode associated with it that the
so-called rationalists are actually
perfectly capable of going insane in a
form that looks like um effective
altruism that in in effect you have
people who imagine that they are the
folks most focused they are the most
hard-headed practical folks with respect
to figuring out how to get the Earth to
be a better place and they have signed
up for a fancy version of
utilitarianism and the thing about
utilitarianism utilitarianism the
greatest good for the greatest number
sounds pretty good don't you love a
planet in which we did whatever created
the greatest good for the greatest
number awesome sign me up okay how about
slavery what if we take a small number
of slaves and the net impact is good for
lots of people then the cost of those
slaves is a small price to pay for all
that goodness right so are we on board
with slavery ah so now I know that
utilitarianism is a problem the the
rationalists have a problem which is
that they have signed up for a fancy
method that they've become very
practiced in without spotting that their
very obligation to that method is itself
the guarantee of a dramatic failure
right right so there are limited places
where static rules will work over the
long
term there are limited places I think
that's a very good way of saying there
are limited places where static rules
will work over the long term and so what
I'm really arguing is when we say
something like there there's
neurological evidence that the Mind
functions in a basian way we've actually
already got it wrong what is almost
certainly taking place is that the mind
has the capacity to function in a basian
way and the mind also has the capacity
to function in a scientific
falsificationist paparian way should you
be a scientific falsificationist
paparian not all the time right and so
the the question is in a cartisian
crisis is there a method that gets you
out of it no there won't be a method
because each of these methods is
actually a failure mode and especially
if you have antagonists that are working
to um disrupt your capacity to make
sense of the world then that's even
worse than just a chaotic World in which
you have tremendously noisy evidence and
they're having trouble making sense of
it and
so I guess the point is and I think I'm
just following up on your argument that
it's the static of the rules that is the
problem and you know we we've said this
in the context of things like child
rearing static child rearing rules are
destined to be gained and so the way to
properly raise children is not to
obligate yourself terribly much to
anything so that you're free to depart
when when you have to but the idea is
there's no method for making sense that
doesn't have a failure mode what there
is is a meta method
yeah I guess I don't I don't think
that's right I think
um only if you narrowly define method
only if you narrowly define method as
this is the thing that you do there's
one thing that you get to do and it
might be complicated it might be a
script it might have a lot of steps but
there's the one thing as opposed to
there's at least two
modes that you have to be willing to
exist in and you have to be willing to
jump sometimes between modes when least
you want to when least you expect it
even sometimes when it feels like but
this is working for me like not
necessarily maybe go back to the last
point on which you were sure and just
try a different branch even if the one
you're currently on feels good so um the
thread that we started with has some
follow-up and I was a little surprised
at just a coincidence that actually one
of the people who respond to that thread
was alexandros marinos friend of ours um
very high quality ther and he described
something that I thought was interesting
along your lines can you uh show that
and
actually maybe I can dredge it up here
cuz you have no way out um so I will
recover as best I remember what
Alexandro says that he does he he finds
it very important in order to avoid the
confusion um from the thread that this
started off with I'm I'm sorry I'm
confused I don't know what a thread is
and what what thread were we on the uh
Dr Tim Kelly thread you're talking about
Twitter yeah okay yeah Twitter thread
right the the the literal concrete hold
it in your hands Twitter thread
um so what Alexandra says is that he
finds it important
to
maintain competing
hypotheses and accumulate evidence for
them
independently now a that's I don't think
that's how I do it um so I think he's
telling us something about an
idiosyncratic method that this very
effective thinker has for solving part
of this problem which is that he
effectively opens a separate file for
multiple hypotheses and he doesn't let
them touch we're talking about multiple
hypotheses for a single observation to
explain a single pattern yeah right
otherwise it's this is obvious right
right right right um so in so doing one
does not fall into the Trap of having
your having found a bunch of pieces of
evidence that point in this direction
being unable to see the evidence that
points in that direction we have
multiple competing um hypotheses and the
point is well all right the evidence
that points to this one goes in that
folder um but in order to avoid the
confusion if I have a separate folder so
everything that should degrade this
folder actually just contributes to this
folder and then later on I can put them
together and I can and say what does all
the evidence on this topic say right
that is a formalization I've never heard
it before that
um solves a problem but the key thing is
interesting um I
often like the way Alex thinks through a
difficult puzzle he's very good at this
but it's also
not it's not that he's found the way
it's that everybody who's successful at
thinking carefully has found a way that
keeps them off of the rocks that the
various Sirens call
towards and that
process so
the longtime viewers will have heard me
say various things like I'm
concerned about a hazard buried in books
the hazard being that it's very it's
something that is book length causes you
to adopt somebody's perspective for long
enough that for many of us it's hard to
get it out of our minds when we're done
and so there's no way to provisionally
test things out without it having a
profound effect on the system so I
freely admit that that's probably not
true for most people but for me that
seems to be a piece of the method the
other thing that I have said
is I don't think
the method that I understand myself to
use can be defended
in uh rigorous terms in other words it
is
um it's an art not a science and so the
question
is
um how do you if it is true that if
what if none of us know our method right
our conscious minds are aware of certain
features of our method but then when we
get to a place like oh formulate a
hypothesis I don't know how that works
well I mean this this is exactly it so
you know I'm going to even object to the
it's an art not a science formulation I
I don't like
that comparison at all because I think
um that the creativity the unknown the
ineffable the intuitive the Lial in
science is absolutely necessary and most
people who don't do science believe
these yahoos who are like just it's data
driven just take the data and throw some
stats at it and like you'll have an
answer and then you'll know what shots
to take right like that's that's how we
get to some of this insane totalitarian
nonsense and that's not where the
science starts right like that's not to
like just throw a throw some heuristics
at and see when you get an answer you
like and call that science but you know
the an the careful analysis of
quantitative information is of course
part of most scientific processes but
the the necessary first part the
generation of the hypotheses how do you
do it how do you teach it you've said
you can't teach it I've said I used to
do something around teaching it but it
was really a like going to drop you in
the field and see you know see what you
see tell me Tell your peers what you see
and start generating ideas for why you
think you saw what you saw not why you
think your brain told you what it meant
but like why why that pattern that you
no
and though that hypo that generation of
hypotheses stage is not logical it's not
rational it's not numerical it's it is
none of those things um that is the
creative the linal the intuitive the you
know observant part of this which is
very much a necessary part of the
artistic process as well now Art and
Science are both seeking truth in
different ways right and what happens
after that looks different in Art and
Science but I would say that that part
of it that part that you are saying you
know it's art not science no no no like
both that's that's both that's that's an
that's a piece that is in you know that
is a necessary part of the scientific
process as well we just we it's not
quantifiable it's not in the rational
logical analytical interpretive space
it's before that and then there's
another piece which you haven't brought
up uh which is that if if you're going
to try to formalize this and there and
there are pieces within this again
creative limal space that you have to
try to
formalize uh you need to say I've I've
observed a thing I want to explain the
thing what could possibly explain that
thing you can't come up with one
hypothesis and you can't come up with
you can't say ah I need to come up with
five like five is the number right you
have to come up with all of the possible
hypotheses uh if a method like say was
it Alexis is going to work or you know
or anyone's like if if you haven't
actually come up with all of the
possible hypothesis to explain in the
pattern you're trying to explain at the
point that you then go into full rigor
falsificationist mode and you're like
okay not a falsified that not B falsify
that oh maybe c not D not e oh it's C
well it's only C if you had the complete
solution set to begin with and you know
that piece of it is also you know you
can say it I I can say what I just said
but how do you teach the development the
generation of all of the hypotheses and
how would you know like how would you
know when you've got the complete
solution set you know in part by well
okay I'm left with C but you know rinse
and repeat I got to do this over and
over again and I I have to know from
having tested those five say to start
with hypothesis about the pattern that
I've observed oh I actually came up with
some more ideas while I was doing that
that I didn't see it at the beginning I
can't test those now while I'm already
in the middle of testing ones that I had
in advance but once I go and well C is
the one left standing it doesn't mean c
is true but it means C is more likely to
be true than any of the others and I
have more confidence in it being true
than I did before but now let me add GH
and I because I've generated those in
the meantime and hopefully you generate
fearer and fearer and at some point you
are left with say it C like okay you
know what it's hypothesis C after all
that's the one that I think is true but
all of that is outside of the realm of
numbers and logic and rationality at
some level it's it's this interplay of
you know modes if you will but it
includes not just the if you know
if and then and thesis ant antithesis
and synthesis but also the what if and
how odd and I'm curious about like it's
it's that space that is where the
scientific imperative starts and it's
why children act like scientists until
they're told they can't possibly until
they understand calculus and that kills
off scientific inspiration in children
and so it's it's both of these things
and yes there are moments when we need
to separate it like I don't think we
want the limal ENT Str statistical
analysis exactly um but but for a lot of
the process it's it's both and well
well I have a couple thoughts just based
on laboratory of the self MH I have the
sense first of all when I say it's an
art not a science I'm not saying it's
art I'm saying it's an art yeah so we
just we have a number of ways of using
the various words right right yeah so an
art means it is a skill that cannot
be
um fully
described so the you know I don't know
ballerinas are virtuosos but if a
ballerina is particularly gifted right
we do not have some method for knowing
how all of the neurons fire that get her
to do exactly the thing that evokes
whatever she's evoking better than
others right but it is something that
she is undeniably tremend tremendously
practiced at doing and she ain't doing
it consciously
right so that the the
analogy that I think that I've used that
I'm I've been thinking about that I
think is relevant
here is uh that art is to craft as
science is to
engineering oh let me think about that
art is to craft science is and and part
part of the reason that works is not
relevant to what you're talking about
right here that both craft and
Engineering are outcome focused or um
I'm going to do this with an analytical
understanding or creative understanding
um but I'm trying to build a I'm trying
to solve this right uh and Art and
Science are trying are engaged in
Discovery and you know revealing
something that is true about the
universe that even the person the artist
or the scientist at the very beginning
of the process may not know that they
are trying to reveal at the very
beginning of the scientific process you
don't know what question you're asking
you don't you may you have some idea you
have made some observation but you
haven't even generated the beginning of
the hypothesis yet and that's still part
of the scientific process oh and the
scientific process has to include
whatever the process is by which a
hypothesis is formulated obviously but
there is no method for it that we can
describe right and what you've described
is a method for yes I grant you teaching
people to do it but as you describe it
it's mostly about immersing them and
right it's about saying
see if you can't find something that
reaches this objective I want you to
come out with a hypothesis what's a
hypothesis well it's a potential
explanation for something that you've
seen for which you don't know the
explanation right well how am I going to
do it I don't know go try and at some
point you're either going to figure it
out or you're going to discover that
there's no route in here that this is a
skill for some reason you can't figure
out how to access and then you got to do
something else um but I also wanted to
pick up so my point is I'm I'm sure
there's methodological stuff going on in
the unconscious layer when I formulate a
hypothesis I'm sure there's a method and
I know I've gotten better at it so
something got trained to do something
better there's some method running I
just don't have access to it any more
than I have access to the you know
sending the muscle some particular
information about how how to lift that
object right I can't tap into it but
here here's the other thing you say the
right way to do science is to formulate
all of the competing hypoth
that might explain a an observation now
I agree if if the method that you
described Alex using if if you're
putting into bins if you're accumulating
evidence into the bins y you don't know
as much as you think you do at the end
of that if you didn't have a complete
solution set of hypotheses to begin with
right now here's here's the point to do
that kind of science to do empirical
science so I know because I did not I
did not use the phrase that you just
used which one uh to I don't know what
what did you say to do the right kind of
to do science you need to do X I don't
remember exactly what you said but I'm
not AR I'm not defending that because I
don't I don't think it's true and I
think it's interesting we now have
evidence on how Alex thinks he does this
and we have evidence on how you think
you do this and I know I can point to
two examples where what I'm doing
doesn't match either of these things no
so now now we're off the rails I was not
talking about my process at all I I was
not describing anything about what I do
I was saying that you do not know at the
end of the day if you had a bunch of
hypothesis if you only have one left
standing if that one that is left
standing is true unless you had all the
hypotheses to begin with that is what
I'm saying that that is the end and that
is that is just true that is that is
correct right but to do with a
particular method there is a statement a
an Arthur conand Doyle quote probably
the most famous quote of all that gets
invoked all the time and I can't figure
out why anybody believes it you know the
one I won't get it exactly maybe Zach
can look it up for us but it's something
like uh once you have
eliminated
uh once you have eliminated all of
the impossible
hypotheses whatever remains uh no matter
how improbable must be the truth or
something like this and as only if you
had a complete solution only if you had
that's my point right but how would you
know but this is also my point so that's
why I said you so you have to go you
have to cycle back the scientific method
is is inherently a cycle so you're left
with one standing you don't stop right
you don't stop there you have to say
Okay well what what else emerged as a
possibility then you're never done you
never know okay when you've arrived at
truth you get closer and closer to
thinking ah this is probably it okay so
I'm going to give you two examples from
my own history as a developing scientist
in which um something else happened
outside of the possibility of having all
the solutions all of the hypotheses in
the solution set or continuing a cycle
of generating new ones and it doesn't
match Alex's version either of um
competing files for
evidence and the two examples are when I
was doing my um
um qualifying exam as a graduate student
so this is an early exam after the first
year I wrote a paper on monogamy in
mammals and there was a
fact that didn't make any sense to me
the fact I'm trying to remember exactly
what the setup was but in cat trickin
you had which are maret and Tamarind New
World New World primates of a particular
claim right you had um I can't even
remember what the observation was that
uh you had twins you had obligate
twinning and you I can't remember is you
have polyandry
and it's it's something around po Andre
and obligate twinning and um you have
brothers taking care of each other's
kids you brother you had
um you
had individuals who were
collaborating as if identical
twins who it seemed logical had to have
been so cckids in question produced
twins the you had males collaborating on
the raising of Offspring as if twins but
the uh embryo ological evidence
suggested that they were not identical
twins and that did not add up to me MH
what I found out many years later was
that there was a weird cellular
phenomenon where the cells in
individuals actually intermixed and so
the animals themselves were Composites
of two individuals so not technically
identical twins but it's something I
would never have thought to hypothesize
right it's too weird I didn't know the
uh crazy but true phrase chimeric
so chimeric testes are testes where the
individual who possesses them doesn't
know which genome they are borrowing
from to create sperm so it results in a
statistical as if identical twins
Behavior based on some mechanism that
was just outside of what was known or
knowable at the time that I was
formulating hypothesis so anyway my
point is in that case what I did was I
you were left with a I can't make sense
of this I know there's something not
true no I don't have the answer but I
know I don't have the answer because
something about this does not fit it's
not even I know I know that I don't know
the answer it's that these animals are
behaving as if they are twins I am told
that they are not that they are behaving
as if they are identical twins I'm told
they are not identical twins I don't
know if the people who did the
measurement got it wrong and they are
identical twins and the fact that
they're behaving like it is really the
real piece of information I didn't think
to hypothesize this other thing because
if I had hypothesized it then there thr
a grad school right I might have been
thrown out a grad school but there also
if if you're going to be that weird
about it yeah right you know maybe
they're not monkeys right who knows how
many hypotheses that are extremely
unlikely to have anything to do with
anything you would have to hypothesize
so I didn't do that but the point is
when I when I finally saw the piece of
information that answered the question I
had reserved judgment I I'm not going to
finalize this file
because that because they're behaving
like identical twins godamn it and
there's just but you but but this is
this is consistent with what I'm saying
you're not disagreeing because I I have
not proposed a method that you don't do
right I have said um one of the errors
that people make in imagining what it is
that science is is uh you have an idea
you test it it's either you know you
either prove it wrong or you prove it
right like almost every piece of that is
wrong right like that's you don't prove
it prove it right um You you know you
may fail to falsify it fail to fail to
prove it wrong and then maybe depending
on how many iterations you've done of
this and how many ideas how many
hypothesis you've tested you may really
feel like that that feels right and all
of this other stuff that I can't quite
figure out where it fits it also seems
to fit with that and so you know what
I'm going to call it good for now and
please all of you future scientists go
ahead and test this and you know if I
turn out to be wrong I will be glad to
know that I would rather not be wrong
but if I am wrong I will be glad to know
that and what you have done here is you
and and always and we all should be
doing this is you say in this case you
didn't even think you'd arrived like the
literature thought it had arrived at
something and you're like doesn't
doesn't work and here are the
inconsistencies that apparently no one
else in literature is talking about and
you're going no I don't know what it is
that the answer is going to be but I am
almost sure I think you would have said
I Almost sure that either something
about what we think is true is not true
or there is something trly extraordinary
that explains these sets of things
because otherwise it does not add up and
it's interesting you know we we I end up
at this like reductionist quantitative
like it does not add up but this is
exactly this part of science where it's
not about the quantitative it's about
it's about again you know something in
the like creative and the Lial and the
like H I can't quite put all of it
together but I'm sure this is not a
coherent picture yet right and back to
my point about
indefensible yes right there is a belief
in the world that we scientists behave
by a code and we should um and that code
involves a method to which we are
obligated and it doesn't matter you know
if the if the method produces an answer
that you don't like tough that's your
problem and the real answer is sometimes
the method tells you that you have to
change your belief because you had it
wrong absolutely and sometimes you
didn't have it wrong and the method
because
all of the various contributing factors
has spit out a temporary answer that's
more misleading than
informative and so so you know a a
proper method a proper meta method has
to contain what I call the agnostic box
which is when you have something that
doesn't resolve and the evidence that
should by some superficial analysis
force you to a conclusion that you
cannot accept because something about it
isn't right you have to have some way of
filing it so you don't you don't get
special privilege for your belief just
because it seems more right than the
evidence you've been told to reconcile
it with but y you reserve the right not
to do anything thing with it to wait for
further Evidence which may frankly take
decades um
and what I want to point to in the
present is there are many different
factions on many different topics ipcs
that are now looking for your membership
card in a particular club and as soon as
you give them your membership card in
the club then you're going to get
thrashed against the wall because you're
violating its rules and the point is I'm
not signing up for those rules I'm not
signing up for the atheist rules for the
universe I'm not signing up for the
paparian falsification rules I'm not
signing up for rationalism and uh
effective altruism
I am signing up for the ability to
utilize these things as necessary and
not you know there's I've forgotten who
who it owes to but there's a famous
statement um I think it's Supreme Court
Justice I'm not sure which one um the
Constitution is not a suicide pact right
and the idea is yes these rules are
written down they're quite clear but to
the extent that one discovers that these
rules are going to force you to
self-destruct obviously that's not the
intent of the people who wrote them now
it's a very dangerous idea because once
you say well it's not a suicide pack all
you have to do is declare something
suicide in order to get an exemption
right so it creates that other Hazard
too right it is both not a suicide pack
and it has to function very much like
one up until some very late moment
otherwise you get you know viable
presidential candidates who are
distasteful to some large number of
powerful people declared
insurrectionists um and you know voila
suddenly your Constitution
evaporates
um so I'm not quite sure I'm not quite
sure where that leaves us
except what are we going to do about the
fact that we
both need to have methods by which we do
things and need to have exemptions and
we now live in a world in which the very
fact that there are exemptions has been
gamified to invalidate the meth methods
themselves H how do we navigate that and
maybe the point is actually all of these
things are predicated on a higher value
which is not stated which is that you
know here here's a place where science
will not work
it will not work in an environment where
we are not agreed that
uh we want to figure out what the truth
is right now if Pharma is in your
science apparatus does Pharma want to
know what the truth is no it wants
marketable drugs sometimes the truth is
very inconvenient for a marketable drug
the drug is too dangerous it doesn't
work there are competitors that work
better right so you know Pharma is going
to get you to free it from truth in
those cases far like engineering is
outcome driven and so it claims to be
doing science but it is outcome driven
it is Seeking a solution uh to a problem
that has identified sometimes to a
problem that has itself created um but
it is Seeking a solution to a problem
that it has identified yeah but let's
put it this way I'm less afraid of the
engineers and I'm afraid enough but I I
I'm in favor of all four of those words
that I used I'm just saying that there
are different they are different work
modes but the problem with the Pharma
one in particular
is that if you take there are pills you
can take in which you can monitor an
effect on some symptom that you're
tracking right so you know it has
positively affected you with respect to
the thing that you went to the doctor
for but you can't tell whether it has
also increased your likelihood of
getting cancer unacceptably for
example for that you have to go to what
looks like science that describes the
consequences of taking that thing and of
course the people who live and die by
the valuation of their
corporation um have perfected the gaming
of the appearance of science when
they're doing the opposite of science
they're in fact disrupting science from
discovering truths they don't want to
hear
and I think it is true that the
engineers are just less prone to this
because I mean well let's let's let's
Steel Man the case that the engineers
are in just as bad a spot I I I I did
not make that I know I'm just steel
Manning trying to figure out whether
there's really a reason to make a
distinction um a distinction between
between Pharma and its objective based
universe and engineers and their
objective based Universe there so many
differences there are
um I guess I'm just I'm not sure what
what that serves I don't know I don't
know anyone making that argument so I
don't know why why we need to pretend
that engineers and and farmer people are
the same um I'm wondering if if you got
to where you wanted to go
um yeah mostly I guess I would flesh out
one other example of the thing that I
think eludes everybody's method but must
be defensible because of its
significance so in addition to the
krickets the other place where I know
I've had the experience of being stuck
with
information and not being able to
formulate the hypothesis that turned out
to be
true is Hutcherson guilford's prera is a
is the most aggressive of the anti of
the accelerated aging pathologies a
progeria is an is an aging pathology in
which people age faster than they should
and Hutcheson guilford's pereria is the
most extreme where you've seen pictures
of these little boys that often have
strange kind of beaked faces they are
balding they appear like little old men
and they rarely make it to 20 if I
recall correctly and they have
interestingly every pathology of
advanced age with two exceptions two
exceptions which I found very important
when I was doing the thamir work the two
exceptions are cancer and demen I their
minds work like little boys' Minds not
like old men and they don't get
cancer and so I knew
that there was bound to be that this was
not an illusion that the fact that they
had all of the other pathologies meant
that this really was in some sense an
accelerated aging and so I thought they
must have short
teirs and they
don't and I couldn't figure out why that
was but I knew that it had to be
approximately there it was rather a lot
like the monkeys are behaving like twins
or like identical twins even though they
aren't um and in this case it was
another hypothesis I never would have
thought to formulate which was that kids
with this disorder their cells are
somehow very
impermanent so that it takes five cell
divisions to get one that sticks so they
basically burn through their lifetime of
Aging at a fast
rate but it doesn't they don't start out
with initially short tiir it's just they
burn through them really the rate not
the initial length is what's different
right right so anyway I guess my point
is look if I was trying to teach
somebody how to do this kind of work my
point would be I don't know what the
name for that thing is where there's
something that feels certain to be an X
and the evidence says it's not an X and
so the answer is it's something in that
neighborhood I can't think of yet right
I'll know it when I see it and I reserve
the what is the hypo hthis that says um
there's something in this neighborhood
that will have the following description
and I'll know it when I see it but I I'm
not smart enough to figure it out
right so anyway that doesn't sound like
a defensible method right I'll know it
when I see it right that sounds like
cheating but so I'm reminded and it's
not clear if this is actually was
actually Isaac azimov but um my little
bit of looking over the last few weeks I
think it probably was um his his
suggestion mid 20th century um that what
we imagined what our our sort of fairy
tale version of scientists the greatest
moment for them is Eureka is I found it
I knew what I was looking for and I
found it and he says no that's not the
thing that the scientists that the
scientist says when he or she is um at
their
most powerful and also uncertain it's
that's odd that's funny that's odd is
what is what I find as the as the actual
quote if it's actually true from Asam
also that's curious is attributed to him
sometimes but that's odd I wasn't
expecting this I wonder what it means
right and like that's that's the moment
of actual um beginning of insight and
and our world of actually you need to
know exactly what it is right now you
need to know forces is into certainty
and we are all way too comfortable being
way too certain of all sorts of things
about which we have no reason to be be
certain and th this is also the scourge
that is happening to science but it's
happening to
everyone so I'm strangely reminded of a
joke which I
think sort of
um suggests where I think we're we're
ending up here I hope I don't get the
joke wrong but um you've got uh some
kind of a situation a hurricane has
created tremendous flooding and a guy
is on his uh his roof as the water is
rising and
um a dog swims up with a a life
preserver and he pushes the dog away he
thinks
no I'm I'm a devout person my God has my
back I I I don't I don't need that and
the water is rising and Rising he's
moving up his roof and next thing a a
guy in a boat comes by and says hop on
he says no my God will protect me guy
with the boat goes and gets somebody
else and then uh helicopter drops a
ladder and shouts that he should climb
the ladder he says no I my God will
protect me and
um helicopter moves on and the guy
drowns and he gets to heaven and he says
God where were you God said I sent you a
dog a boat and a
helicopter um so you know I guess the
point
is religious people have never
been there is always the duality of you
know lots of scientists have had deep
faith that was technically in conflict
with something about what they were
studying so what that's the way it is um
likewise there's a it turns out to be
from a song um I didn't realize this but
uh praise God and pass the ammunition
right the idea that these two things are
not in Conflict right God is not that
kind of creature right the point is
you're still in battle and you're still
praying to God or whatever but I I don't
want I don't mean to overly focus on the
religious modality maybe it's just
useful because it's the most remote
for analytical types you know it's the
one that is most easily jettisoned
initially jettisoning it probably has
made benefits but I think it seems the
most easily jettisoned I don't think it
is actually jettisonable entirely and it
is exactly the hubris of the wouldbe
analytics and scientists who think that
they do not have faith who have dragged
us all into a land of um you will have
faith in the name of Science and it's
diabolical and extraordinarily dangerous
right and and as we've seen and as we've
talked about on other episodes a lot of
the folks who managed to see through the
madness of Co actually had Faith uh in
their prominently in their toolkit which
tells you something but anyway the
um I don't
think I don't think we know how the the
mind works but I think
um somehow carving out a mechanism where
one cannot be held to the details of a
particular um modality or cannot be
convicted of hypocrisy right sometimes
you and I get challenged by the no virus
people or um the no covid people or uh I
don't know I saw one in the uh the piece
we covered with uh Denny Rancourt on the
last live stream uh with
the uh the all cause mortality it
numbers for Global death as a result of
the vaccines he says something in there
um
about uh pathogens do not abide by
political
boundaries um and each time I hear
somebody say that I
think that can't be right you know
you've got a virus in this case it
doesn't um doesn't transmit outside
right it's not very frequent that you
would cross a political border inside
and you know nobody crossing a border
can have those effect in any
case
um it's something about the requirement
that we leave room to defend the
indefensible because indefensible
doesn't mean that there isn't some
higher order defense that could be made
it's just that we don't necessarily have
access to
um to the substance of that
defense indeed we need to leave
ourselves open to defending what seems
to be indefensible because what seems
indefensible today may prove to be The
Only Thing Worth defending
tomorrow let us end with a brief excerpt
if we may all right um from Dickens A
Christmas
Carol I think it's um because I promised
it I want to do it um even though it's
not exactly it's not anything about what
we can doing so
far this was first published in
1843 the door of Scrooge's Counting
house was open that he might keep his
eye upon his clerk who in a dismal
little cell Beyond a sort of tank was
copying letters Scrooge had a very small
fire but the clerk's fire was so very
much smaller that it looked like one
coal but he couldn't replenish it for
Scrooge kept the coal box in his own
room and so surely as the clerk came in
with the shovel the master predicted
that it would be necessary for them to
part wherefore the clerk put on his
white comforter and tried to to warn
himself at the candle in which effort
not being a man of a strong imagination
he
failed a Merry Christmas Uncle God save
you cried a cheerful voice it was the
voice of scro's nephew Who Came Upon him
so quickly that this was the first
intimation he had of his approach bah
said scroe
humbug he had so heated himself with
rapid walking in the fog and frost this
nephew of scrooges that he was all in a
glow his face was Ruddy and handsome his
eyes sparkled and his breath smoked
again Christmas a humbug uncle said
Scrooge's nephew you don't mean that I'm
sure I do said Scrooge Merry Christmas
what right have you to be married what
reason have you to be married you're
poor enough come then returned the
nephew gay what right have you to be
dismal what reason have you to be morose
you're rich
enough Scrooge having no better answer
ready on the spur of the moment said bah
again and followed it up with humbug
don't be cross uncle said the nephew
what else can I be returned the uncle
when I live in such a world of fools as
this Merry Christmas out upon Merry
Christmas what's Christmas time to you
but a time for paying bills without
money a time for finding yourself a year
older but not an hour richer a time for
balancing your books and having every
item in them through a round dozen of
months present a debt against you if I
could work my will said Scrooge
indignantly every idiot who goes about
with merry Christmas on his lip should
be boiled with his own pudding and
buried with a steak of Holly through his
heart he
should Uncle pleaded the nephew nephew
returned the uncle stly keep Christmas
in your own way and let me keep it in
mine keep it repeated scrooges nephew
but you don't keep it it let me leave it
alone then said Scrooge much good may it
do to you much good has ever done you
there are many things from which I might
have derived good by which I have not
profited I dare say returned the nephew
Christmas among the rest but I am sure I
have always thought of Christmas time
when it has come around apart from the
veneration due its sacred name and
origin if anything belonging to it can
be apart from that as a good time a kind
forgiving charitable Pleasant time the
only time I know of in the long calendar
year when men and women seem by one
consent to open open their shut up
Hearts freely and to think of people
below them as if they really were fellow
passengers to the grave and not another
race of creatures bound on other
Journeys and therefore Uncle though it
has never put a scrap of gold or silver
in my pocket I believe that it has done
me good and it will do me good and I say
God bless
it I have felt that way about this
season about Christmas it meant that in
my family uh which was mostly without
religion growing up and um I love it for
them and we are lucky to be here with
our family and among friends in this
Christmas season and um we hope that you
are too
excellent all right uh we will be back
uh a day later than usual next week on
the 28th on
Thursday and um you can of course join
us on rumble on locals join me at
Natural Selections uh we have uh dark
hor store.org where you can get Jake's
micro Pizza merch among other things and
um maybe I'll just leave it at that
until we see you next time be good to
the ones you love eat good food and get
outside be well
[Music]
everyone